and different stages of the analysis are
performed in different sections on this
multi-atomics platform
so first of all let's begin by signing
up on the portal before that let me walk
you through a brief demo on what a
completed profile on the portal looks
like so once you sign up on the portal
these are the features that you need to
update on your account that is a
completed profile will have a profile
image full name with appropriate
capitalization link to your social media
handles this could be your Facebook
LinkedIn Instagram Arc ID or even
Twitter a brief bio about yourself that
will consist of your education
background and research interest the
mentors can view your progress under the
activity Tab and the courses you are
currently completing will appear under
the course step and finally after the
completion of your course the
certificates will appear under the
certificates tab so with that let us
Begin by signing up on the women's logic
plan portal I'm sharing the link in the
chat box please click on the link and
I'll walk you through the process behind
signing up on the footer
so here is the link
all right so for users who do not have
an existing account on the portal please
click on the create an account option
that you see here
here you will be asked to enter your
name email ID and provide a new password
and you also have the option to sign up
using any of your social media accounts
that could be your Google account
Facebook account Apple account GitHub
account or even your Twitter
so once you have signed up please put a
yes in the chat box I'll wait for a
couple of minutes so that participants
can sign up on the portal
since today's session is going to be
Hands-On it would be great if you could
create an account I would sell so that
you could get access to the resources on
the portal as well
so once you're done signing up on the
portal please put a yes I'm monitoring
the chat as well
or if you're facing any technical issues
while signing up on the portal please
put them in the chat as well and our
team will be happy to help
all right sure and pause for a couple of
moments so that you can sign up
so for those of you who already have an
account on the portal just click on the
login now option since I already have an
account I'm going to click on the sign
in and proceed with it
so once you sign in you're able to view
the various courses and example projects
that will be uh that will be appearing
under the courses tab so so please feel
free to browse through the list at your
own pace so since most of the
participants here will be interested in
Precision medicine
just enter the keyword decision medicine
and you'll be able to see the various
example projects that will be associated
with today's topic
so if the participants are facing any
kind of technical issues or having any
queries so far on signing up on the
portal please put them in the chat I'm
just proceeding along so that
we don't delay the program so now coming
to the part about updating our account
so just click on the tab that says
welcome back with your email ID
so how do you update the profile uh like
I said so so that click on this button
that's his profile so here you will be
asked to upload your profile image your
education background your name with
appropriate capitalization and as you
can see here I've linked my LinkedIn
account and my orc ID
so you can also choose to link your
Twitter or Instagram or Facebook
and the and the mentor of the program
and the community manager will be
tracking your progress under the
activity tab and if you're completing
any courses for example right now I'm
completing python codes too it will
appear under the courses Tab and once
you upload any projects it will appear
under the projects Tab and finally if
you're enrolling for the program such as
the mathematics Corporation medicine it
will appear under the programs tab and
finally if you complete any courses you
will be able to receive the certificates
under the certificates tab so I hope all
of the participants have signed up and
if you have any queries so far please
put them in the chat otherwise we are
good to go we are good to start with the
session for today
do we have any queries has everyone
signed up
all right we have it done all right so I
hope rest of the participants have
signed up as well otherwise if you have
any queries please feel free to put them
in the chat uh for now I'm passing on
the stage to Dr ragle to start with
today's session so over to your doctor
thank you very much let me find you guys
to share my screen I interviewed all of
you get your
registration done
so can you see my screen
and hear me
yes yes what are working fine okay
perfect thank you very much so welcome
to today's webinar on bioinformatics for
precision medicine uh so we know that
Precision medicine is actually changing
the way we understand diagnose and treat
many diseases right that also include
cancer and this transformation of the
way that we treat diseases is actually
driven by high throughput sequencing
data that is high throughput sequencing
molecular data that we get from patients
for diagnosis and prognosis purposes and
for animal models from animal models to
actually understand the understand the
disease that we are actually dealing
with and we can also perform a large
scale seller and experiments to uh
characterize the responses of different
diseases and specifically tumor also to
several of the treatment options that we
have lined up for them
so uh
to compare with Precision medicine
traditional medicine uses symptoms to
diagnose diseases and drugs to treat
these symptoms but Precision medicine
aims to turn this approach on its head
right Precision medicine is an emerging
approach for disease treatment and
prevention that takes into account
individual variability in genes and
individual variability in environment
and different changes in the lifestyle
for each and every person this approach
or such an approach will allow doctors
and researchers to predict more
accurately which treatment and what kind
of prevention strategies are will work
for a particular disease and in which
groups of people it is expected or it is
understood to work better
so this is in complete contrast to one
size fits-all approach that is in which
the disease treatment and prevention
strategies are developed for an average
person with less and less consideration
for the individual variances and the
individual differences so after a lot of
research we are poised to enter a new
era in the medical practice where
detailed genetic and other molecular
information about the patient's disease
is routinely used to deploy effective
and patient specific remedies to treat
it we are about to enter the era of
precision medicine
so the future of medicine is
increasingly driven by the availability
of data and the expansion and the
standardization of high throughput
sequencing that results in medical
practice that is both Ultra and Ultra
personalized and Ultra precise
extracting meaningful implications from
this data requires deep analytical
expertise and it also requires
integrating several of these data
several of these omics data from
different molecules so let's take a look
at what we got here and what drives this
change in the modern medicine actually
the role of bioinformatics in general in
the context of diseases is to allow
researchers to access to process and to
analyze
uh and and also to visualize several of
these kinds of high throughput
sequencing data that we will get
introduced to over the course of this
program and this program will also
introduce you to several examples of how
this connection between this mixed data
and their explanation or the reason
behind the diseases and their
effectiveness into several treatment
options was done successfully by
researchers studying for example viral
infections like Ebola virus outbreak in
West Africa we will also take examples
from covid-19 pandemic as well as we can
also study microbial pathogens causing
uh for example tuberculosis and
development of resistance to several of
the treatment options and antibiotic
that this tuberculosis encounters it to
we will also we can also consider cancer
and their responses to different
treatment therapy critique options that
we have and in the end we will also have
options to work with single cell
parasite that causes malaria so we will
briefly touch on viral genomics viral
Evolution and gene expression patterns
and detection of significant genomic
variants as well as some important
aspects of microbiome and Byron
community in a hosts that are being
studied to find important associations
of these several different omics data
with disease susceptibility and disease
outcomes as we move along
yeah my uh animation is running slow
so
cancer I don't have to introduce all of
you to cancer cancer is the leading
cause of death worldwide and this
accounts for nearly one in six deaths
right some of the most common cancers as
we know are breast cancer lung cancer
colon cancer rectum cancer and prostate
cancer
causing infections are prevalent and
they are such as
papilloma virus and hepatitis virus or
responsibly responsible for
approximately 30 percentage of the
cancer cases in countries that are still
under developing or still developing
right so many of these cancers can be
cured if they are detected early and if
they are treated effectively and this is
where Precision medicine is applied to
enable early detection of cancer by
studying various different molecular
drivers in these tumor cells and in
these tissues that are responsible for
the for the tumerogenesis and for the
tumor progression
uh is this the case if somebody else can
confirm can you hear me
yes so we can hear you yeah please check
your speaker settings thank you for your
confirmation
so as we already spoke about cancer
cancer is one area where in Precision
medicine seems to be making significant
head away right a new therapist seek to
Target the specific cellular pathway
that is being exploited by cancer with
the view to make something like a short
life of tumor or with the view to make
intervention to the tumerogenesis and
the progression of this cancer
so that exists and urgent need to
identify new biomarkers or novel
signatures that will help us in early
detection and prognosis and new
biomarkers and signatures can be and are
in fact identified by leveraging
publicly available omix data resources
from the Cancer genomics Association or
tcga from ncbi resources and from
various other public resources which you
will get good introduction and good
um demonstration in this program to find
the data and to download the data and to
process and analyze the data so that we
can find some novel associations with
the disease progression
so the field behind this omics data
analysis is the big data bioinformatics
and this has developed tremendously in
the last several decades that
transformed life sciences and that
enabled bio biotechnology and also is
empowering biomedical research to a
completely new facet so as a result
there came many new discoveries from
researchers from analysis of existing
omics data that includes new treatment
that includes diagnostic assays that
design strategies for novel
experimentation that will confirm the
effects of these identified biomarkers
treatments and assets
so the main catalyst as we discussed for
the transformation of the biomedical
research is the emergence of sequencing
technology and in this program we will
introduce you to sequencing methods and
particularly Next Generation sequencing
methods or high throughput sequencing
technology that will help us study
genomic variations have genes and their
expression RNA transcripts and their
parts in the disease progression and how
all of these molecular elements are
linked to disease biology
so to give you a sense of how this
genomics data came into existence then
we already know that that is that it's
it's already been most 50 years since
the time of sequencing of the human
genome and in around 2015 the 1000
Genome Project brought significant
number of whole genome sequences to the
research community
for analysis and for uh finding
implications that 100 000 whole genomes
were sequenced by 2018 and today there
exists or there there is an ever
increasing number of data sets that are
available to help researchers to
understand cellular processes to
understand molecular functions and in
the context of disease biology and in
the context of for example
um
rare diseases and also in the context of
cancer biology
so this growth of high throughput
sequencing data is largely driven by the
cheaper faster and more efficient
sequencing of Next Generation sequencing
or simply NGS right from around a
billion dollars in 2001 to around
approximately three million dollars in
2008 and by 2017 alone the cost of a
single sequence genome was close to 100
one thousand dollars and the aim is to
reach around less than 500 or 100
dollars by 2025 I believe if I'm not
wrong so this has put a tremendous
amount of tremendous volume of data that
is available genomic status that is
available which is driving the whole big
data bioinformatics uh
field false so
this technology like NGS can be used to
explore the rules the relationships and
the actions of various types of
molecules that make up the cells of an
organisms and many types of these omics
data can be generated using as we know
right the Next Generation sequencing
technology and we will also study or we
will also discuss in this program how
this data can show detailed information
about genomic variants and the patterns
of Gene and isoform expression and the
differences in the microbial communities
that drive the differences in the
disease biology
so the economics of this data are hugely
or extremely important for clinical
practice and translational approaches of
the implications that we can find and
associations that we can find so far
Medical Data as simply clinical data to
introduce you to is a type of
information that we have been using for
centuries right it's like measuring
temperature measuring heart rate
measuring blood pressure and other
symptomatic data that is on the surface
these are typically easily and quickly
measure or cheaply measured and are
covered appropriately by insurance but
with the Advent of molecular biology and
cellular biology and with the Next
Generation sequence of Technology we
have learned how health and diseases are
driven by what's happening but this
subcellular level or what's happening at
the
intercellular level and biomedical data
refers to the combination of all of
these omics data that characterizes the
subcellular level of the disease biology
with the clinical un relevant clinical
data that is happening at the surface
right
and these different omics data include
genomics proteomics and even microbiome
of a patient that can be related to in
the difference in which that these
microbial communities help us process
the metabolomics that we have in our
project
so to give you an example of one of
these omics data types and how they are
used and how they are how they actually
change the approach so as a method of
measuring RNA translation
transcriptomics data or transcriptomic
studies can actually help us detect mRNA
expression inside a cell as an accurate
alternative to measure membrane protein
expression which is actually used for
example traditionally to let's say to
characterize tumor histologically this
change in approach to focus on the
molecular Precision in a molecular level
actually change the Precision in
improved Precision in Diagnostics and it
also enabled development of treatment
based on molecular Pathways instead of
observational chemistry or observational
characteristics of diseases specifically
tumor
so the classification of tumor itself
has changed or it's it actually uh
started to include molecular
classification in addition to
histological classification or
functional classification that one can
observe or that one can obtain
superficially and this includes for
example
uh classification at the level of
molecules with complex variation across
genomics and transcriptomics data and
also variation that will also include
risk profiling of the patients based on
the models that can be generated from
the data trends that we find from these
genomics transcriptomics proteomics and
even metabolomics data and to give you
an example in addition to the existing
Pam 50 classification and histological
classification of breast cancer we now
have a separate set of molecular
classification for that characterizes
breast cancer in in terms of luminal a
or luminal b there's a like or normal
like the flooding low Etc and these are
also described or these are also
demonstrated to be extremely important
to classify as several of these
different classified subcategories react
differently or respond differently to
treatment options or therapeutic options
so the significance of the data that we
just discussed is huge as cancer can be
diagnosed earlier and the treatment can
be selected and adapted as the new data
is generated and the drug safety can be
monitored driven by the complex modeling
of the disease progression themselves
not based on The Superficial or not
based on the
um
what I'm looking for is a
response related data but it's based on
subcellular and system-wide data symptom
not based on the symptomatic data but
based on the sub-cellular molecular and
system work data that was what I was
looking
so in short the gene expression pattern
for example can be Associated or can be
integrated with the clinical data and
this can help us identify molecular
biomarkers for Diagnostics and for
therapeutic selection and new
discoveries include better understanding
of complex diseases at the subscillary
level as well as it can help us in the
Target identification for novel drug
design it can also help us repurpose
existing drugs for different purposes
one of the very famous example is the
usage of Metformin drug which was
traditionally or which is still used for
used to treat diabetes is actually reap
getting repurposed to treat
clinical cancer data are we supposed to
be anti-cancer drug in certain
conditions based on the omics data
analysis
so what this actually creates is
this creates a disconnect between for
example the data that that is obtained
with from the lab technicians and
clinicians and the data that can be
processed and understood from the
biomedical research ecosystem based on
the data analysis method and data
analytics that we can perform uh using
bio bioinformatics this disconnect
actually breaks up the cycle of
innovation due to lack of data-driven
research skills among the otherwise very
effective biomedical Personnel that we
have in in dealing with increasing
demands and increasing uh changing in
the unpredictable landscape of the omics
data that is currently present so to
fill this Gap what we need to do is
we need to develop a more
um for example
um
ecosystems that are prone to
put on to be decentralized and that are
proved to be data driven approach right
and we have been given a taste for this
current scenario
from thanks to the pandemic or not
thanks to the pandemic this has already
started to affect Health Care and More
subtle trends of disease management and
Drug development are also been observed
right and these industries are most
affected as uh going decentralized for
laboratory is has been found very
difficult and and many several harsh
coveted protocols has to be taken to
enable working inside this laboratory
environment but on the contrary
data-driven approaches in large-scale
projects can be performed in a
decentralized
manner and this is key to the future of
clinical and biotechnical
biotechnological Innovation where we
have plenty of mixed data we have plenty
of clinical data and they are waiting to
be approached in a data science oriented
or a data science
approaches and in this program we will
ensure that you get a taste of how this
is done by taking data from different
sources and then we will perform
analysis on the server Associated high
performance Computing server the server
how about bioinfo server and then we
will show you how to make the
associations from the omics data to the
disease biology
based on our analysis on this data
so we will also learn
about basic and translational research
in for example oncology where the
patient derives cell lines or xenograft
models and clinical trials offer a rich
collection of data to to for example
help us treat cancer in patients and
help us give informative diagnosis at
the patient level
so um
this has a mentioned has completely
changed and it has given us a
complimentary information
uh approach towards this is biology
where we have traditional biological
hypothesis based approach can help us
validate once we have identified
specific markers and specific
therapeutic responsive agents elements
that we can use in the traditional
approach to verify and traditional
approach to build very extremely
targeted assay based methods to
understand
um different for example understand
personalized and precision medicines
reach to
cancer patients who are responding
differently to different things
so how do we go about this for example
as I already introduced you so we have
to uh analyze and we have to uh for
example
um consider data from different sources
like from different molecular sources
from different uh
um even different sample sources like
microbial composition of our bodies and
with the environment that it is actually
thriving in and how they are responsible
to responsible for destabilization of
the immune system and that leads to
clinical manifestation of disease
specific to the microbial abundance in
specific parts of our body and we can
also relate or integrate cellular omics
data with clinical phenotypical data
which is done at a several different
integrative levels that can be
associated with common diseases and that
can also be associated with specific and
rare genetic diseases and that can be
associated with cancer also in many
these different situations right so
do we have promise to develop new
methodologies and new informative
approaches to data that has already been
present or do we have to resort on
generating new data but we can see from
this graph that there is an information
explosion and there is an increased
Reliance on the data due to the lowering
of costs that generate these detailed
and large data so however there is an
ever increasing of growing information
lag that complicates and the
translational approaches of this data
into practical and impactful insights at
the point of care so this is where or
this is what we call the analysis Gap
and this this is proportional or this
depends on our ability to generate new
data and our ability to process digest
and analyze the existing data to
interpret it for the benefit of the
individual patients so existing data
such as data repositories from the
cancer genome Atlas or data from ncbi
can be used to find novel approaches and
can be used to find novel biomarkers or
can we use can be used to find
biomarkers specific to specific
ethnicity and race and demographic
classifications of
and do that
so to what we actually address in this
program is to oh it went wait a second
that's
yeah
so what we want to address in this
program is to close the gap by focusing
on the central issues that Define the
Precision medicine right by we will
offer you training and support and
effective tools to manage process and
analyze and also to integrate the data
so that we can make a lasting impact and
we can find a novel associations and we
can
at some day change the future of
Medicine
so our first headache or for first
challenge is to what do we do to analyze
this data in order to analyze this huge
volume of data one has to resort to the
methods or one has to
um uh address the computation complexity
of analyzing this humongous volume of
data for example
um a genomic data of a single cell can
can reach the
sizes of
tens and tenths of GB if not hundreds of
GB right so what do we use to do or what
do we use to perform analysis on these
data right and
this is just one of the major challenges
that is related to for example uh omics
data analysis to accurately and to uh
effectively process large-scale data
assets that represents gigabytes
sometimes even terabytes of data so such
large quantities of data can actually
prevent many of us to gain tactical and
Hands-On understanding and Hands-On feel
for what this data represents and what
are the patterns of this data right so
let's let us
quickly have a demonstration or quickly
have a Hands-On
um
overview of various methods of analysis
for for example to help you overcome
these major limitations so this is how
this is we will do this also let's go
back yeah this is this is one of the
addition
uh this is one of the pipelines uh that
you will set up in order to understand
or in order to associate transcriptomics
data with different uh tumors subtypes
specifically considering breast cancer
in this case right you will get access
to Hands-On exercises you will get
access to the data assets that we used
for practice and these data sets are
curated so that the analysis will run
quickly and you will also get access to
where we got this data to the
publication that from where we got this
data and these data and several steps
that involves in processing based data
for example we have to pre-process this
data we have to perform the analysis by
mapping this genomics data or
transcriptomics data up to the reference
genome uh human reference zero and in
the end we have to identify variance in
our data or we have to identify
or we have to quantify the expression uh
levels of different genes in by
including appropriate analysis methods
for setting up the pipeline let's say
for transcriptomic data analysis or for
genomic set analysis so one of the
results that you will get is such as
this where we can identify genes that
are differentially expressed uh in the
deceased State compared to the normal
state or normal tissue this can also
help us identify genes and Pathways that
are enriched for example in a tumor
tissue compared to the normal tissue
that is obtained from the same patient
or in a tumor tissue and
data from normal tissue that is obtained
from healthy individuals
so we will learn about some of the
important projects and some of the data
that it collects and that
um
in the cancer genome Atlas is one of the
very important repository that has a
collection of large quantities of
several different Comics data for over
30 tumor types we will get a detailed
introduction to navigating this
repository finding important analysis
finding important data from this
repository we will download relevant
data from this repository and perform
analysis uh pertaining to Precision
medicine to yeah to understand how this
repository can be leveraged to
perform
a project in Precision medicine let's
say
on the other example or on the other
hand we will also deal with data from uh
from patient derived cell lines so these
are data that are generated from one
from Under One Roof or from a laboratory
where they consider several different
several numbers of
patient derived cell lines and
characterize these cell lines for
multiple omics data types so the
advantage of using a model system like a
cell lines data over patients data that
is observed or that is up that can be
obtained from cancer genomic Atlas is
that these patient-derived cell lines
can be
subjected to several analysis several
experimentation methods for example in
this study
um these cell lines that are derived
from the breast cancer patients are
actually first characterized at
different molecular level and also study
for their responses to 90 different
drugs right so now we have data that is
that characterizes these cell lines or
tumor at multiple molecular economics
level and also we have data of their
response to several different treatment
of options so from by integrating these
two data we will get how
um how we can effectively identify
specific molecular characteristics that
can be associated with the positive or a
sensitive response to a therapeutic
option or negative or resistive response
to several therapeutic options then we
can use these biomarkers and apply that
to Patient data from tcga for example to
identify or to
has stratified patients who are
most likely to respond to the treatment
options that we have identified from
this study so this example project will
also be deal dealt with in tremendous
detail in the upcoming program
so this is yeah for example uh if we
have to identify and Associate the omics
data to the clinical data this can be
done using data that we download from
the cancer genomutlers as we we have
been we have been going through in this
case we have an example project project
that deals with liver hepatocellular
carcinoma and how various clinical data
available on those patients for example
their risk factor and their demographic
information and their for example
disease history in terms of hepatitis
virus and their complications can be
associated with the molecular
characteristics or molecular or mixed
data like um
mRNA expression or gene expression data
and micro RNA expression data so these
these Association and integration can be
made in in in this project and this will
also be discussed in detail
in this
in this program
so we will in addition to this look at
for example phylogenetic tree
reconstruction uh to understand the
spread of Ebola virus outbreak in for
example around 2016 and because we don't
want to focus only on the cancer we want
to explore the Precision medicine
approach to infectious disease research
where it is where this specific branch
of precision medicine is fastly
improving and are being applied to
several different
disease States so another example that
we will consider is to study sarscope to
genome and the cell's responses as well
as we will see how metabolomics
metagenomics are microbiome data is
associated with the disease and drug
response so these are also we will
consider in this program
so for different parts we will this been
already covered by SRI gowri but we will
leverage the omics logic resources
go back again it's running or it's not
running yeah so we will leverage these
resources for example we will use
asynchronous coursework we will use the
cloud-based analytical server where you
can analyze large genomics data and we
will use for example code based
lessons where you can also practice
coding in R and Python and we will also
use several of the project examples that
uses published data or that uses data
from a publicly available repositories
so
to proceed further these methods let's
give give let me actually give you an
um
introduction to some of the pipelines or
some of the outputs that you can take
from the server to successfully analyze
omics data into multiple different
analysis uh analysis pipelines that is
going to give you information on the
phylogeny that is going to give you
information on the gene expression
pattern it will also give you
information on the structural and
functional aspects of the variants that
you identify from from variant calling
methods it will also give you for
example help you uh perform surveillance
based approaches and surveillance based
analysis on publicly available resources
for
um
for example for a
SARS genome for a SARS go to study
so let's with a further Ado let's go to
uh server and let me show you how you
can perform this analysis by setting up
a very simple demo pipeline for
transcriptomics data so let me reshare
my uh
foreign
yes can you see my screen
can you see the server
yes we are able to see okay so if you go
to the server T bio info this is a page
that you will take a look at so once you
have some credentials set up so uh this
demo pipeline can be accessed by
everybody who has a credential in server
bio info server uh
um in the Big Data server so you don't
have to be a paid user to analyze uh to
perform this demo pipeline which will
give you an example or experience of
setting up this pipeline the data that
we are going to consider is a cell line
data that cell line data that I have
been talking to you about so that
analysis will come under the
transcriptomics data analysis and you
can for example to set up the pipeline
you can drop down this box
and then choose the option demo PDX
project or sorry let's go here not the
PDX position demo cell line project
so if you click this this is going to
open up into the demo pipeline
and uh yeah so we will start by starting
so this is the input files are already
been uploaded so you just have to follow
the lead of the highlighted uh sections
that this demo pipeline is offering you
and the choice of this analysis method
you will get to know as you go through
the program so first you have to do the
pre-processing
once you select these analysis options
you will get suggestions right I am
getting now suggestions based on what
could be my future step so I want to
perform mapping onto the genome using
hisat 2 and then identify some novel
isoforms based on
my sample and their expression
should be Quantified
and when we do this I will want to
quantify the expression levels of the
isoforms and genes I have mapped onto
the genome and then I want to perform a
downstream analysis or a differential
gene expression analysis which will help
me identify or which will help me
shortlist genes that are differentially
expressed in one type of cellular or
molecular molecular
tissue type compared to the other
so I will end the pipeline
and then by ending the pipeline you will
get Hands-On
approach your Hands-On to several of the
output files that you can download for
example uh we will have
um expression levels uh
of isoforms and expression levels of
genes that are at different normalized
normalization that are performed for
different normalization and as I also
mentioned you will get a statistics of
how well your fastq files are the reads
mapped onto the human reference genomes
so this will become the quality control
of your mapping and we will also get
results of our differential gene
expression analysis that we have
performed by comparing cell lines or by
comparing tissue types that are normal
like compared to the clotting load for
to perform this analysis you need to
have prior biological information about
the sample so this is how you can set up
this analysis and you can access these
output files and if you download this
ZIP file you can have access to all the
plots that differentiate gene expression
analysis the effective produces so that
you can make sense of all the data and
make sense of all the outputs that you
have obtained by performing this Amex
data analysis and downstream analysis in
the server so
I want I urge all of you to explore this
part and explore the demo demo pipeline
of uh of the server and with that I will
stop my presentation and open the podium
for some discussion and if there are
none I will be happy to hand it over to
sparsh
and if you have some questions please
let me know in the chat
um thank you Dr ragovation
um can you please make me co-host
[Music]
you are audible specialist
just like try to share my screen if I
can
as my screen invisible
yes it's visible thank you thank you
um so as I'm not the co-host it would be
great if ayushiya should go you can
share the appropriate Link in the chat
box when I'm discussing or telling about
the registration part thank you
so
hello everyone I'm Superstar and I'm the
marketing manager here at buying biotech
so uh this is I'll be just quickly
explaining you about the registration
part of this particular program that is
bioinformatics or Precision medicine
as you can see that the program has been
commenced from today onwards so today
was the first session of the program and
this is the program page
when you would scroll down you can see
the program overview in the in this you
will get to know why this particular
training program mentality trading
program has been designed for whom it is
designed what are the uh sessions or the
topics we are covering what are the
practical aspects which we are covering
in this particular program if you scroll
down further you can see and elaborate
the comprehensive detailed curriculum of
the program
uh and as today was the first session
the session was on introduction to
bioinformatics or Precision medicine
where Dr Robert has covered all these
topics that is data analysis combining
clinical and molecular data
uh from the lab to the clinic research
Discovery and clinical uses cases case
studies and precision medicine
Etc so the next session is on October 10
and it will be on genomic data analysis
where we'll be covering about the NGS
uh genomic data NGS data analysis of NGS
data and variant following annotations
of variance identification of clinically
relevant mutations Etc so uh as you can
see uh on the right hand side or that
there is an interactive session a
calendar and in the in that particular
calendar you can see some of the dates
are highlighted so these are the dates
when we will be having our next a few
sessions so the structure of the program
is a quite a hybrid kind of that either
some of the session would be a signature
session some would be a kind of a light
key in your live session so we will tell
you and uh we'll mail you regarding the
same accordingly and whosoever will be
like enrolling for this program and will
be the participant of the program
and now uh apart from genomic data
analysis we'll be having sessions on
transcript from data analysis then
phylogenetic analysis in MSA our
response to infections Precision
medicine for neurosciences metagenomic
data analysis advancement in Precision
medicine
and oncology data sources raw data and
public databases and so on so these are
the topics which we'll be covering so
you can go through with the
or these were the sessions which we'll
be covering sorry and you can go through
with the topics uh like in those per
session which we will be covering
further now when you scroll down you
will see three different tenures one is
of 45 days another is of 60 days and
then is of 90 days
so the common resources one would get if
they enroll for this particular program
is
online tutorials project examples coding
session session recordings online Mentor
support and Online technical support VR
Skype Community then certificate of
completion and example Cloud Pipeline on
team bioinfo server now what's the
difference between the three is in 45
days tenure you will have the access
only the
only the online Venture support and
Online technical support and in 60 days
and 90 days you'll be having few more
opportunities in 60 days you will be
having access to the educational Cloud
pipeline the educational license where
you can approach your data set which is
being present in the public repository
secondly you can have access to the
one-on-one Mentor sessions whenever you
get stuck somewhere while going through
your training part you can fix it kind
of exploratory calls with the mentor of
like 15 to 20 minutes and discuss and
clarify your thoughts there now
second thing is uh you have an
opportunity to draft a research proposal
and uh that particular proposal you can
send it to the mentor for evaluation
purpose so it Mentor will uh evaluate
your research proposal and guide you
opportunity so whatever amendments or
changes that needs to be done so as to
make the research proposal more
validated he will guide you accordingly
the outcome for 60 days is a poster
presentation in a research Symposium or
any other International or national
conferences now for 90 days uh with
one-on-one mental sessions uh online
Mentor Support Online technical support
you will have an access that you can
prepare and or you can work on your own
independent research project and the
outcome of 90 days tenure is that you
can have a research publication in a
very good peer review journal so this
was about 45 days 60 days and 90 days
resources now talking about the pricing
part the fixed part so uh
here you can see that there is a drop
down kind of menu and you can change
according to your location the currency
for now I am using USD dollars so the
pricing uh for 45 days is dollar 150 for
60 days it's dollar 300 and for 90 days
it's dollar 450 and we do have
scholarships so
um I guess SRI body can share the
details of
mind like the email address and the
official contact number which is active
on WhatsApp and you can further contact
me or you can connect me via WhatsApp
and we can discuss further about the
scholarship how much we can Avail so
this was a brief about the tenure about
the registration and the pricing part so
if anyone is having any doubt related to
the registration part or the scholarship
they can they like please feel free to
put their question in the chat box and
I'll be there to answer it thank you
what do you should worry
[Music]
all right thank you so much sir so thus
the participants have any further
queries I've shared sparse contact
details in the chat
so if you have any queries please feel
free to get in touch with her via email
or her WhatsApp number all right so I
hope all of you were able to learn
something from today's session and I
hope to see you all for the second
session of today's program with that
thank you so much for your patience and
have a great day thank you
thank you thank you everyone thank you
[Music]